the jurogan experience um another thing
i heard this is really crazy that trump
is going to start a third party
that he's been talking about start
starting a party called the patriot
party which is like
holy [ __ ] i don't know anything about
that
again rear view mirror rear view mirror
i don't believe he's gonna be in the
rear view mirror
i just don't i think people are gonna
get bored i think it's gonna a few
months will go by
or whatever it is until he's in the news
again and then uh it just won't be
exciting without him
and then i think we need a foil we need
someone
look the [ __ ] 2021 season
it's gonna be pretty boring if trump's
not involved at all like if if this was
a
long-running show like ozark or
something like that right
and we get to we get to the new season
when he steps down like this can't be it
no i see what they're gonna do they're
gonna pretend that everything's gonna be
fine we got biden we got harris we got a
lot of uh
really diverse people in the cabinet
this is gonna be wonderful
we got it we nailed it everything's
great and then
something that's what the worry is yeah
well i mean
look there there are sadly
a lot of really important and serious
things
that we could and should be talking
about that should capture
our attention yeah and be able to
as the people provide that pressure to
our leadership and hold them accountable
for whether or not they're doing their
job and actually working for the people
uh or or not are you talking about like
a reasonable
you're talking like a reasonable
responsible person
that's not human but there's not that
many of you out there i think there
are joe i think there are i think we're
a bunch of grown-up babies with phones
and they just we're just tweeting up a
storm and watching youtube videos that's
what i think
i think people are so addicted to this
drama
i mean my god watching twitter over the
last few days
has been like watching people commit
complete an ultra marathon
like they're they're they're getting to
the finish line we're there where they
cross the line and yeah we made it we
did it we did it
it's over [ __ ] you like there's so many
people like
playing you know having memes and this
and and these like
self-aggrandizing posts about like two
directly to trump
dear mr president [ __ ] you and this and
that and
celebrities are doing and all these
people are getting in on it and
it is a fascinating thing to watch
because i'm like okay you made it across
the line
now what what happens next we're gonna
do with all this
you gotta you like the fight you like
you like the conflict
what are you gonna do with all this
energy you got this concept let's
re-channel that let's re-channel that
real problem to actually fight for the
people
against those who wield
uh the power yeah but that's not fun
what's fun is a bad guy
bad guys are fine we need another bad
guy we got plenty of those trust me
we got plenty of bad guys no but we
don't have a bad guy like trump
but here's here's the thing is and i
agree like people who
have been looking forward to
january 20th as though
this is going to solve all of the all of
the problems
that our country has faced uh are
missing
the reality that
the way we got here are because of some
some deeply seated problems that
that have pre-existed uh the previous
administration
and that still exist in our country
today which is why i think it's so
dangerous
for some uh leaders especially in the
democratic party and in the media over
the last few days who
are so easily dismissing
the 70 plus million people who voted for
trump
as though they are all the kkk or they
are all this or that throwing them into
that bin that hillary clinton called the
deplorables
and this is um
the reality of of how dangerous that
train of thought i think is
is going to continue to
[Music]
reveal itself unless look you know
joe biden gave gave a very unifying
speech for his inauguration
it is that the pressure is on him to to
deliver for the country's sake i wish
him well
in working towards that uh
but it's not going to be an easy task
and
um ultimately he will be held
accountable for
for his own actions and whether he is is
able to be that unifying force or if we
end up
seeing and address some of these deeper
seated problems you know
he said in his speech that whether you
voted for him or not that
his goal is to serve you the american
people
um you know again the pressure will be
now on on
him to actually show that is true
through his actions and and actually
actively reaching out
to those 70 plus million people who
didn't vote for him
yeah i mean it would be wonderful if we
all got together united and said
let's wish him well and let's
let's cheer him on and hope he does a
fantastic job and
all of you trump supporters who thought
that he was a puppet of the institution
wish him well like would it for our
country be happy be happy if he's
if he's right and you were wrong catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience